what if I told you that Tetris the
seemingly endless 80s Puzzler could be
beaten what if I told you that for the
first time in history that happened now
what if I told you that its Champion was
just 13 years
old oh my
[Music]
God out of all the games to come out of
the Retro era Tetris has arguably
remained one of the most relevant sure
Pac-Man Space Invaders pong have all had
an immense impact on the gaming industry
but unlike those I still play Tetris and
as it turns out Tetris still has a
massive community and Esports scene
filled with Ds talking strategy creating
content and most importantly showing off
their high scores you see like many
other games from its time and the few
that are still released today Tetris is
an endless game there is no win
condition all you you do is play for as
long as you can increasing your score
but the game always beats you or so I
thought on December 21st Willis Gibson
AKA blue scooty out of Oklahoma became
the first person in history to beat the
NES version of Tetris and he did it at
just 13 years old but how how do you
beat an unbeatable game well you break
it Tetris can't be beaten in the
traditional sense but just like many
games from that time you can achieve a
kill screen you see many of these games
if not all of them weren't meant to be
played forever and since they operate on
older Hardware there's only so much
highlevel gaming they can take for that
reason there comes a point where many of
these games just glitch out and freeze
you get what is called a kill screen and
physically cannot progress any further
which is how you can beat games like
Tetris if the game literally won't let
you play anymore you've
obenson now Tetris specifically has had
a long long history of these supposed
points of no return but if you want more
of the history on that I suggest you go
check out a game Scout's fantastic video
on it but essentially over the three
plus decades that this game has existed
people have gotten very good constantly
pushing further than anyone ever has
before them developing new controller
techniques and well having just pure
endurance however in 2021 an AI was made
to play Tetris near perfectly stack
rabbit made it way past the highest
level any human ever had until the game
just stopped working tetrises true kill
screen had been discovered and later
player hydren dude figured out many of
the possible occurrences of achieving s
kill screen turns out the earliest one
could arguably be reached by a human
which caused a bit of a race with the
biggest hurdle being the increasingly
hard to see color palettes caused by
more technical limitations of the game
just being played for too damn long but
late last year after 34 years
13-year-old blue scooty who had already
been making waves in the competitive
scene did what was once thought to be
impossible he beat
Tetris oh my
God in the week since the achievement
two other top Tetris players fractal and
pixel Andy have also managed to reach a
true kill screen and now it seems that
the future of beating Tetris surrounds
achieving a kill screen as efficiently
as possible or trying to avoid one for
as long as you can but blue scoot will
always be the first and thanks to his
achievement he has absolutely blown up
his story and now the story of Tetris
has gone Way Beyond the reaches of our
relatively small Competitive Gaming
Community basically every single major
outlet has reported on this but as we
all unfortunately know traditional
media's opinions on gaming isn't always
as charitable as we'd like and one
outlet has already tried to devalue Blue
scooties
feet as a mother I would just say step
away from the screen go outside get some
fresh air beating Tetris is not a life
goal obviously this comment didn't go
over all that well at its worst it's
completely out of touch and at best it's
just being mean to a teenager for really
no reason but I wouldn't read too deeply
into it as mentioned traditional media
is still a long ways away from treating
gaming with the admiration it so
desperately deserves I mean covering a
story that's big enough to get airtime
but not serious enough to earn the
respect of those covering it should tell
you everything you need to know beating
a once- thought unbeatable game made 20
years before you were even born is
nothing to scoff at it's a lot more
impressive than anything I was doing at
13 I'll tell you that much so to Willis
if you're watching
congratulations yeah Tetris rules I
still play Tetris on a weekly basis my
girlfriend was a freak at Tetris 99 that
like Battle Royale version forgot about
that that was probably one of the most
go video game songs of all time I would
say